monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Commissaire notre Parlement a fait de
l'Europe en 2019 le premier continent a
déclaré l'urgence climatique l'urgence
est bien là le dernier rapport du GIEC
en témoigne
caribéen j'assiste chaque jour à
l'impact des changements climatiques qui
frappent encore davantage les pays
d'Afrique des Caraïbes et du Pacifique
il n'y a pas que aujourd'hui plus de la
moitié de la population mondiale est
vulnérable au changement climatique
notre objectif de limitation du
réchauffement climatique nécessite une
approche transversale singulièrement par
le développement durable à l'échelle
planétaire le programme 2030 avec les
EDD est une feuille de route
internationale claire et impérative mais
nous prenons du retard nous devons
démultiplier nos efforts aussi bien dans
l'Union européenne qu'auprès de nos
partenaires je veux le marteler ici le
coût de l'inaction sera bien plus grand
que le coût de la transition j'appelle
un sursaut de conscience collectif pour
l'accomplissement du pacte vert et la
mise en place d'un nouveau pacte
financier mondial